alright I'm sitting here with raha
this is Rahad from magic of rahat now do
you have a last name or do you want to
not publicize that it's Hossein Hussain
yeah okay perfect okay so now your your
your channel is the magic of rahat but
do you have like an official title like
rahat the Magnificent or something like
that honestly I've always been known as
rahat or just a magic of hot okay okay
so nothing crazy nothing too wild and
out there I like that simple plays in
this right digital age right all right
oh I wanted to try something real quick
okay I want you to to say a card any
card you want me say it out loud I'm
going please three of hearts I know I
had a woman in one in 52 chance of
getting that right oh damn it
so all right well let the details how
this interview is gonna go but I could
it could have been cool so what we'll
probably do later I'll have you say oh I
don't know the seven of clubs and then
we'll have you get a real surprised
reaction now we won't make it that sorry
about that
all right cool now how long have you
been doing magic I've been doing magic
for about seven or eight years now okay
so now who are your you have any idols
in the the the world of magic are you a
Doug Henning guy
I've heard of Doug Henning before but on
I main influences and magic has to be a
fellow named Paul Harris he does very
like very simple types of magic with
everyday objects and that's the type of
magic I absolutely love where you can
just take you know simply a coin or you
know an iPod or just just anything
that's laying on your desk simply do
magic and is the such an organic feeling
and that's that's what kind of attracts
me his
I love magic so I would say the biggest
influence would be Palhares okay cool so
I haven't heard of them but I'll have to
check them out now tell me a little bit
about though about your relationship
with penguin magic penguin magic is a
company I work for and basically we are
one of the biggest online magic
companies and basically I produce these
magic prank videos that you everybody
seen and basically me and uh penguin
magic itself we kind of work closely
together to provide these great content
for you guys okay
now I noticed on another one of your
sponsors was Mormon org how did that
come about I'm sorry what what was that
again one of your other sponsors is
Mormon org kind of a religious website
so you okay so you don't know what
they're putting at the the front of your
you have kind of a just bit like at a
distribution deal or something where
they just kind of will tack anything
onto the the front of your ads or um
yeah basically okay so yeah because it
was an interesting mormon org and then
the magic of rahat doing you know a fart
prank or something it didn't really seem
to tie together so i was wondering why
they knew what they were sponsoring and
if you knew what you were being
sponsored by so that was interesting all
right so that's good to know
now where are you located out of I am
locating Virginia Beach Virginia okay
and okay yeah now is it true that
northern squirrels don't live around
there unfortunately no they actually
live in Florida kind of weird but who
knows I have no idea do you make all
your own props I do make some of my own
props and then a lot of my other props
on there are marketed effects in the
magic market but a lot of times I'll
take like let's say a like a marketed
trick and I'll kind of flip it upside
down and
my own and you know I could get a
different idea out of it and I do a
prank video out of it as well nice so
where did that I mean it was the the
giant McDonald's straw was that a you or
was that a another break that you kind
of co-opted in that's actually a
marketed trick on on the magic market
and you know that's something that a lot
of magicians do you know in kid shows
you know stage magic and you know the
and I've done this last year where I
went into a in-and-out burger joint and
basically uh I went one night try it
that actually had two straw inside the
bag pulled it out and the people behind
me were like whoa what the heck so you
know at that point I'm like oh man this
is gonna get some good like really good
reaction so we proceeded to get some
more you know footage and we're actually
working we're in the works of making a
second one so that might be out probably
at the end of this year if anything
that's awesome that's one of my
favorites of yours so far so that's good
yeah now do you use a hidden camera
typically or do you I mean do people
just not notice there's a guy filming or
how do you do that um with drive-thru
stuff I do use a hidden camera I kind of
have a rig in the passenger seat and
basically a lot of people don't really
catch the camera at times but probably
you know well mataf or people will catch
it but it's very rare though but um that
people will see the camera because it's
actually pretty well hidden kind of in
the passenger seat but for like
something like Walmart pranks I've never
really been caught with it because it's
so well hidden inside a shopping cart
nobody ever thinks twice it doesn't you
know camera they're looking at or you
know just some product in the shopping
cart now you kind of tend to use a
Walmart a lot in your pranks is that
kind of a commentary on the intelligence
level of people who shop there um I kind
of look at kind of look at Walmart as a
playground with you know all sorts of
different kinds of people you
meet some on on a good night you will
meet some very interesting people but
you know there's there's a lot - a lot
of people you can kind of work with and
they give Val you know everybody gives
off different reactions so it's kind of
cool how that kind of plays out okay now
have you made any syrup bubbles smoke
since you had the cops called the unit -
oh man no because that honestly doing
that was probably one of the scariest
moments in my life and let me explain
like what happened so you know obviously
the lady freaked out she ended up
calling the cops and at that point I try
to record every single you know thing
that was going on and I was actually
ready to book it but you know like no
I'm gonna you know kind of stay here and
see how this unfolds and and I got you
know a lot of footage out of it but
basically actually in the store I
actually have to ditch the card but I
don't want to walk out like you know
suspiciously because then you know me
looking like you know me making a you
know syrup balls smoke you know people
gonna think oh my god terrorist or
something so I don't want to give
anybody that idea so I basically bought
a pair of sunglasses so I look
suspicious you like walking out so I
bought a pair of sunglasses and I went
through a self checkout and I you know
bought the I bought the sunglasses and I
went through the front door and all the
alarms started going off and I'm like oh
my god I'm going to jail like tonight so
thing was a lauren was basically because
they didn't take the tag off the the
sunglasses and basically that's what it
was I thought you know they caught me or
something and they're like you know get
him or something and so like the whole
Tyra ride back to the office I was
absolutely paranoid I thought like the
FBI's were like on me like the whole
entire time
so that's scary I like it I like it
now that was speaking of the cops did
you get a ticket when you were pulled
over in the end of your floating dollar
bill
um I don't know if you were calling that
there's a cop who pulls you over he just
gets the video camera up in time
he kind of notices the bill right um and
that okay uh um I actually didn't get a
ticket he was it was a pretty nice cop
I'm the only thing he really pulled me
over for was a excuse me um because I
had a backlight out and he was like you
know if you just get that fixed you'll
be fine but he saw that floating dollar
he was like you got a you know dollar
about the fire out your window so you
know he thought it was pretty cool so
I'm you know he let me off but it's kind
of funny because like the next day I was
actually kind of around that area I got
pulled over a second time and basically
the cop he saw the floating dollar but
he didn't really you know make note of
it or anything he doesn't really like
talk about it but you know luckily he
led me off as well you just told me you
know get the light fixed and you be you
know good to go but I was actually
thinking about making like a video
series of me getting pulled over purpose
and you know getting these cops
reactions but it's kind of risky though
so you know it might be in the works
yeah the risk reward on that one has
little now which of your pranks have
been the most effective do you think the
most effective one I would probably say
would be the the floating cup series and
the probably a static shock series now
what about the least effective is there
any other just nobody buys and
everyone's just like and I know about
that one man um honestly I would say
probably the magic TV prank where I you
know wave my has make the TVs uh you
know this is something like me and my my
good buddy of Mike we kind of thought
about we sat down or like oh my god
that'd be a really good idea but you
know it was just kind of it was an okay
idea it's not really my favorite video
but you know I think there's we could do
something better with that and we're
gonna actually kind of take a look at
that kind of that prank and see how we
could do something different with it
now how many penises would you estimate
that you've performed for in your
chatroulette videos countless it was
brutal making those videos I think was
about two years ago I've made that
series but I've been scarred for life
I've seen stuff on chatroulette where I
just you know I I wish I could unsee but
unfortunately Charlotte is a very brutal
place and you know there some nights
where I would see something and I would
just say okay that's enough I have to
call it quits for that night it's just
I'm kind of happy you know a lot of
people who are asking me to do another
chatroulette video it might it might
happen but it's just such a such a
difficult thing you know a penis like
every other you know video so it's kind
of uh it's kind of a mental you know
abuse I guess I don't know now has magic
ever gotten you laid yes okay good all
right that's good I mean you're one of
the first guys so that's cool
it doesn't get girls all the time I'll
just you know say that because magic you
know it can be a nerdy kind of thing but
you know if you play it off right you
can it's a great icebreaker for you know
just meeting people in general but if
you do it right you can meet you I guess
you kind of meet girls with it but I
want to see it I wouldn't say it's a
surefire thing though mmm no for sure
well I anything I can use I guess now is
there an end goal to your to your magic
I mean do you foresee you have me would
you ideally want like a Criss Angel
style show in Vegas that kind of thing
or are you strictly going to stay on the
street you know I used to do a lot of a
lot of gigs like birthday parties
corporate events in a lot of parties
before this phoned her you know YouTube
thing happened and you know I enjoyed
that a lot
but I think it's come to the point where
I think doing these videos I'm you know
it's kind of taken over a little bit and
I'm really don't have a lot of time
doing you know these kind of shows and
stuff but maybe sometime in the future I
am hoping to maybe do like a stage show
or allow any any of like you know event
where I can know I kind of meet my fans
and you know put on a great performance
and you know just entertain everybody
and that's that's something I kind of
see in the future happening yeah you
certainly got the views for it so you
have a is there any other YouTube
channels that you watch the channels
that I usually watch would be Jack bales
another one would be ed Bassmaster um
you know I'll watch you know people like
CTFxC Smosh i watch a lot of like tech
reviews like you know soldier knows best
ties I help you know TechnoBuffalo um
you know just a lot of like get a lot of
stuff on YouTube and stuff okay so where
is where is the magic of rahat five
years from now let's say I am hoping if
I were thought work hard enough I kind
of want to see myself get to the top
okay so well thank you very much for
sitting down with us and it's been a
pleasure and new media rockstars is
excited to see what you do next awesome
thank you cool well thank you very much
for hot all right have a good one all
right thank you for having me
YouTube you
you